[Music]
okay a michigan superintendent
has denied
uh that litter boxes were added to the
school bathroom
for students who identified as furries
no [ __ ] why
what do you mean like they're like we
don't do that but they do
well no they he says that
um there's a bunch of litter boxes that
appeared
but i didn't do it i didn't do i didn't
authorize it is it so kids could pop a
squad and take a [ __ ] like they're a cat
the furry kids probably put those right
identifies the furry when you identify
as a furry do you identify as like a
furry animal is that what that's short
for yeah so yeah furries were people
that like to dress up in um
like cost like fur costumes
girls don't even worry about it so joe
it's like full commitment all the way
just cats who like to dress like this
yeah it's that [ __ ] and they need a
litter box they got a [ __ ] whoa can i
use a urinal why would you because
you're not you're a furry you don't wait
people identify as that
yeah yeah what's wrong with that no i'm
not no i'm just learning about it can
you let me learn you guys
jesus christ dude [ __ ]
teacher brother host
so check it out
yeah so like you know the furries are
totally normal and this is totally
normal this is like just like as regular
it's just like you're born male or
female furry furry it doesn't matter
they got some big conventions for these
two
you know where it all started it was
started in our childhood when they're
like it doesn't matter if you're white
black purple or yellow and it's like and
some people were like purple
who the [ __ ] is purple
grimace
people that it goes too far yeah
it does get purple yeah people get
purple true
the grape flavor drinks you know it's
like purple
but it's like maybe that's when they got
it in their ideas like i could be
anything
anything you want and i'm like i'm gonna
be a [ __ ] furry you know that's what
happened i
i hate this idea of telling children you
could be anything you want you could
even be president no wait why can't they
be president too because it's [ __ ]
ridiculous uh joe no they have to be 35
so they can't be president yeah a child
cannot be president a child cannot be
president so what are you talking about
literally doesn't matter
he just debunked you right now yeah i
can't believe it yeah
they can't be president
what's the appeal to furries though if
you're a friend what do you think if you
were trying to convince anthony lee to
be a furry
it wouldn't take much
just knowing him yeah it's just it's
already closed
i'm sure there's like a a lure like most
things so close
i think it's what kind of furry animal
would you be
it's like larpers right
i'd be a cashmere [ __ ] elephant
cashmere fox yeah cashmere elephant so
you guys know uh silent mike one of his
close buddies in norcal is a a school
teacher and now the new policies and
whatever like the kids identify with you
have to address them as that so if they
if they say table you just got to be
like mr table they go because so one of
you were human one of the kids literally
said i'm batman
so now by the law the teacher has to
call them batman it can't be like travis
i'm sorry uh because then they can get
sued that's a great law
it's batman and they can change every
single week today i am phone book can i
be black panther or probably not you can
probably whatever you want yeah you
think oh you think so because i think if
i said i was black panther somebody
would have an issue you're calling me a
gay fox and you're on that an issue can
i you're well you have gave up gay fox
vibes
can i be black panther
you have no black panther vibe
you think so show it
i give you all this credit and say you
have gay fox yeah give me nothing with
black panther you're always credited
bro like [ __ ]
that's a black panther body that's his
move that he does when he fights in the
the bad guys
albino guy
that's the name of him his when he's in
the tribe yeah
when he's in wakanda they're like
bring up i know and then he comes in
breaks albino okay
so the super
bring ivory boy
the superintendent has denied rumors
that schools have added litter boxes to
bathrooms for use by students who
identify as furries
quote it's unconscionable that this
afternoon i'm sending this communication
at all
midland public schools superintendent
michael e
wrote in a post to facebook he says
however our midland stakeholders may be
confused but a false message accusation
that has resurfaced this week is gaining
traction in the social media realm
furries by the way are individuals
anthony go ahead and take it away
who go ahead
okay
do you want to define it who take a
particular it's such a good setup an
anthropomorphised
animal oh yeah that's what
anthropomorphized that i knew it was
going there you said that earlier today
do you know what that is already it is
um um mighty morphin power just to study
anthropology no he's been he's trying to
before
animals with humanoid features thank you
thank you
that's right thank you
um so they wear animal costumes or tails
or ears or anything i saw this one furry
manga porn whew that [ __ ] got me harder
what animal was it
or manga
oh like anime like hentai
imagine that category i
dude they were in the forest and then
there was two like like furry wolves and
they were [ __ ] so the furries are
face of animal body of humans no
uh like yeah it's like a body of cubans
had titties hybrids oh sweet dude i saw
stacked up i saw manga of cheetahs
[ __ ] at 60 miles an hour it was crazy
[Music]
they're pushing 68 69 miles an hour yeah
and they had a little odometer at the
bottom
it's hot dude with every page the
progression is amazing because physical
copy oh so manga is in the comic book
yeah
manga manga
manga manga
they found that um litter boxes were
discovered
in at least one all-gender restroom in
one of the school districts
for students who identify as cats that's
what they claim they claim that it was
there for that reason they found it
there they claimed it was there for that
reason
um damn is this one big prank or
something
uh no
you gotta take this generation seriously
dude what the [ __ ] man they say well he
says our community
our community needs to understand that
the agenda that is being pushed through
our schools is somewhat nefarious when
it comes to some of these activities so
let's talk about first let's actually
have a conversation about first
um let me be clear in this communication
um
countered the superintendent there is no
truth whatsoever to the false statement
such accusation i have never there have
never been litter boxes within mps
schools which is the uh michigan oh so
he's saying they were never even there
yeah oh that's what he's saying
uh the kids have pictures of them gotta
deal with nowadays it's a little bit
of he should
she said
see what i'm saying
because like she said uh because he
should and then like maybe like the
kitty said too yeah i should say oh no
wow like yeah she said what if your
children come out
as a furry what would you do
i think i would
i'd probably give a note to to some guys
in a japanese subway
yeah and then what
and then yeah probably overdoses
[Laughter]
that's that's a reason though that's a
good reason that's a good reason you
know what's kind of an upside though is
that like as weird as they are they
that's a community that doesn't really
[ __ ] with anybody that's true like they
just want to have their fun they don't
really like put it in your face much
is have some fun they
they don't even like force you to
recognize them at all
they don't they don't force you to like
identify anything
if you're a furry how much of your life
do you live as a regular human being and
then how much of your life nine hours i
think i thought it's only when they're
around other furries okay you know i
didn't have a little cousin that was
furry and her really sexual thing or is
it like cosplay i think that it's a
sexual thing it's like a misconstrued
thing like it's kind of like an
all-around everything that comic i saw
was hot all the time not all the time no
only when they're like within their own
people
in that sense like you have your day job
but then when you participate in larping
it's like there are rules and everybody
needs to participate in the ecosystem
with these rules yeah do that thing
where they walk around a little tokyo
all together like they don't even do
that like they just have their private
stuff and they just don't want to be
[ __ ] so they don't take hormones to
try to look like that they don't want to
take hormones to dude they just put a
cushion on you like
what what constitutes identifying as a
furry then if you can kind of just go
back and forth because i think it's it's
just you're identifying as being part of
the furry community you just dress up
and use the litter box it's like a it's
like a big it was a big thing on tumblr
too they had like huge
communities on there i just remember
like hey i like the fact that they're
not like [ __ ] with anyone that's yeah
i think their dream job is working at
theme parks or like chuck e cheese and
being the people in the costume maybe
those guys are posers though
is there like a list of like things that
humans have identified with just so what
you know we can understand what's like
politically correct there's probably a
2021 instagram pronoun thingy because uh
michael jackson changed it to he he
whoever owns his account changed it to
he he really yeah
you